on continue la tournée des smartphones
fin 2019 avec un smartphone que je vous
ai testé depuis quelques temps qui était
présente elle aussi actuellement c'est
le readme cinq smartphones qui est cool
c'est très intéressant dans l'entrée de
gamme parce qu'il est hyper hyper hyper
concurrentiel 169 euros faut vraiment
leur situer par rapport à son prix c'est
un sérieux concurrent par rapport à ce
qu'on trouvait chez les fabricants
chinois notamment de chiens oui je vous
montre ça vous de me dire maintenant ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
[Musique]
non
avant de vous parler de ce joli
smartphone je vous parlais de sécurité
parce qu'un sujet qui est vraiment très
intéressant et juste avoir une vidéo qui
réalise aujourd'hui en partenariat avec
kaspersky biométrique ring je vous le
traduisent le fait très simple sa nano
biométrique fait par kaspersky
alors c'est pas un objet de metric vous
allez pouvoir acheter c'est un concept
un concept est en cours de développement
mais qui montre vraiment ce vers quoi on
peut aller en terme de sécurité pour
sécuriser votre smartphone vous fait le
pitch très facilement que ce soit avec
un rythme et 5 ou n'importe quel autre
smartphone vous utilisez vos données
biométriques pour déverrouiller votre
smartphone par exemple ici la
reconnaissance faciale rambo smartphone
seulement facile reconnaît je deviens où
ces pratiques autre point pour
déverrouiller c'est le capteur
d'empreintes digitales mon smartphone
est verrouillé je mets mon dos derrière
le smartphone est déverrouillé ça vous
le connaissait ça marche très bien mais
qu'est ce qui pourrait se passer si
quelqu'un venait à pirater vous données
biométriques pouvoir débrouiller
n'importe quel de vos appareils
quand on sait ce qu'on arrive à
sécuriser les données biométriques que
ce soit en termes de cartes bancaires en
termes de smartphones en termes de
beaucoup de choses même de mot de passe
global on se dit que le jour où notre
sécurité est compromis c'est compliqué
parce que vous pouvez pas vous faire
repousser un index avec une nouvelle
empreinte digitale
vous pouvez pas vous changez votre
visage donc si ces compromis c'est qu'on
premier s'est compromis à vis du
courrier les sociétés comme kaspersky
qui se posent des questions qui se dit
comment est ce qu'on peut utiliser des
données biométriques qu'on pourrait
changer si besoin est justement leur
idée c'est de travailler sur une barque
alors ça un anneau qui est créée en
collaboration avec benjamin way qui est
un designer d'accessoires en trois
dimensions suédois c'est donc un anneau
vous allez pouvoir utiliser un anneau
unique qui est imprimé en trois
dimensions qui vous permet de
déverrouiller votre smartphone pour
comprendre comment cette bague
fonctionne il faut savoir c'est une
pierre qui est imprimé en trois
dimensions en argent qui comporte une
pierre biométrique qui est composée de
milliers de fibres conductrice suspendu
d'autres composés de caoutchouc avec un
motif d'empreintes digitales unique que
fait le capteur d'empreintes digitales
de votre smartphone dubaï va lire le
motif directement sur votre bague et il
faut aussi vérifier la conductivité de
la pierre en gros comme si c'était votre
doigt cette vague elle va voir
sensiblement les mêmes caractéristiques
que votre doigt à la la même forme
physique et à la même texture pour être
reconnue au niveau des capteurs dans
comme digitaux allait donc des figues
conductrice qui vont activer le capteur
le capteur d'empreintes digitales va
faire avec la pire exactement ce qu'il
fait avec votre doigt il va prendre le
motif il va comparer par rapport à ce
que lui en mémoire et s'il le reconnaît
paf qui déverrouille le vrai
eric vous avez c'est que si vous perdez
votre pierre ou si elle est compromise
ou quoi que ce soit et bien vous pouvez
bien à changer votre doigt non je vous
aime bien la description pour en savoir
plus sur cette techno savoir comment ça
marche
comprendre un peu toutes ces
problématiques parce que le vrai que
lorsqu'on n'a pas vu ça comme ça on se
dit pas forcément que notre empreinte
peut être corrompue que les données
d'autres visages peuvent être récupérées
corrompu et qu'à ce moment là on est
vraiment embêté parce que comme je vous
dis une fois de plus eh bien on a dix
doigts avec dix empreintes digitales en
main vous soyez utiliser votre or taille
pour venir déverrouiller gauthier auquel
cas ça peut être quand même relativement
mettant hors de période d'été vous
balader en tongs ou si vous lui et dans
des pays où vous allez donc toute
l'année vous avez tous à hambach
description pas dépasser un sujet qui
est vraiment très très passionnant et
qui porte vraiment réflexion puisqu'on
parle de capteur d'empreintes digitales
il faut que vous sachiez que capteur
d'empreinte digitale du riz le mi5
fonctionne très très très bien vous
posez votre doigt sali dairou bon c'est
chose qui est éprouvée qui est connue
qui reconnut qui marche bien les moyens
à ce que j'aime beaucoup sur ce
smartphone c'est son dos je trouve
qu'ils ont fait une espèce de doit de
défendre holographique c'est sympa ça
marche bien c'est très efficace et
différenciant pour le coup c'est très
joli
on retrouve le branding ici riehl 1090
vital d'envoyer gardien d'un goal bouton
pour l'allumer pour l'éteindre de la
recharge est ici au micro usb on n'a pas
d'usb c'est surprenant mais pourquoi pas
haut-parleurs micro priziac ça c'est
bien bouton de volume
ici vous avez votre tiroir de quartier
pour mettre une double edano estime
possible est une extension de mémoire de
256 giga n'est cependant pas dans
quelques instants
vous avez à l'avant vous le voyez ici
petite encoche goutte d'eau important
que quand même un petit peu pro imminent
mais bon on va les rassurer sur un
smartphone qui coûte quand même pas très
très très cher donc ça me paraît assez
normal écran qui écoule 6,5 pouces on
n'est pas sur un écran d'un gros nez sur
un écran lcd on est sur une résolution
de 1600 par 720 pixels c'est du hd si
c'est pas du tout du full hd ni du full
hd + 2 169 pixels par pouces un écran
qui occupent 89% de la face avant
corning gorilla glass 3 plus et surtout
l'écran la joue l'un des pôles modifié
mais il est très très très très très
bleuté à garder ce qu'il faut faire
c'est bien dans vos paramètres ici alors
moi je suis allé directement dans
l'adaptation nocturne j'ai un peu triché
regarder je vais le désactiver c'est
déjà un peu plus bleuté et il est là par
défaut et là par défaut franchement y
pique un peu les yeux un peu mal ce que
j'avais fait par défaut j'étais venu je
l'avais mis en plus chaud servi un petit
peu vous réchauffer l'écran mais c'est
pas complètement dingue moi ce que je
vous conseille vraiment c'est de venir
dans l'adaptation nocturne et vous
l'activez directement vous mettez par
ici la voyez placer le curseur par là
c'est pas mal parce que si vous
descendez c'est quand même froid
c'est un peu trop mais encore ça
fonctionne vous mettez par là comment
vous avez une solution qui est pas mal
qui va un peu venir lutter contre la
fatigue oculaire ça me paraît en tout
cas aller dans le bon sens pour venir
regarder du contenu multimédia ça
fonctionne la vanille qui sont à la
petite encausse là mais on est sur un
smartphone qui paraitra cher c'est
normal ça fonctionne ici haut parleur
mono bon la qualité audio il pas dingue
dingue aussi vous en avez marre
d'écouter comme ça il vous reste europe
je coupe il vous reste deux solutions
soit la prise jack on a branché un petit
casque déjà la qualité audio est bien
meilleur et l'expérience sera augmentée
soit sinon il n'y a pas que vous avez
quand même du bluetooth 5.0 vous prenez
un casque bluetooth vous le connecter et
là par contre c'est quand même
relativement tranquille donc du point de
vue aux jo ça fonctionne une vraie
question galope je change tout le monde
y ait fait ou directement avec vous je
vous cacherais il ya une autre question
qui se pose au niveau de la performance
ici en à sa dragonne 665 on est sûr de
l'entrée de gamme ça paraît quand même
relativement normale 4 gigas de ram 128
jia déstockage comme jeudi pourrait
monter jusqu'à 256 giga en fonction de
vos besoins on a un score sur un ton
tout 272 1997 qui va venir le classer
entre le samsung galaxy à 50 et le
samsung galaxy à neuf de 2018 on a donc
des performances qui sont vraiment très
honorable qui vous permet de jouer à
beaucoup de jeux du plestan qui est
quand même relativement fluide mais
surtout de gros gros gros gros gros gros
gros point fort ce smartphone et je dis
avec beaucoup de r c'est la batterie
vous avez une énorme batterie j'en ai
racheté dans batterie de 5000 millions
terreur autant dire que vous êtes
vraiment tranquille on a une des
meilleures d'autonomie que j'ai pu voir
sur un smartphone pouvoir qu'on laissera
cependant à 169 euros c'est énorme dette
entre 2 à 3 jours d'autonomie
alors nous allons jusqu'à quasiment 28
jours d'autonomie sur le site de rulhe
me font ça un peu exagéré peut-être que
si vous coupez tout vous baissez la
lumière il vous fait rien pendant
quasiment 28 jours ça marchera pour moi
trois jours vous les avez et c'est en
tout cas une belle avancée c'est
vraiment bien ça vous évite de vous
poser la question des vols smartphones
par contre après il ya un manque un
petit peu négatif derrière c'est que
vous avez eu de la recharge uniquement
en micro usb il n'y a pas de recharge
rapide
donc si vous n'avez pas pensé à le
changer et vous arrivez enfin de charge
de la batterie
eh bien vous êtes un petit peu dans une
saison un peu délicate vous avez un
chargeur d'iwate inclus il vous faut
beaucoup de temps pour recharger il faut
s'armer de patience c'est vraiment un
smartphone qui vont venir brancher le
soir débranchez le matin parce que sinon
vous allez vous voir
non vraiment vraiment vraiment galéré
ici au niveau de l'eau est on sûr
colorware si ce que l'on voit ici c'est
sympa ses origines alors il faut aimer
mais j'aime bien pour que là-dessus
qu'un bon boulot qui ai fait ça se
retourne sur un android 9 paille c'est
sympa on comprend vraiment bien il ya
une bonne lisibilité lowe s est vraiment
de bonne qualité de toute une partie
pour les jeux vous avez un espace de jeu
mais maintenant des points intéressants
sur ce smartphone c'est la partie photo
est ce que vous avez quand même beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de capteurs
première caméra 12 mégapixels ouverture
f 1.8 vous pouvez aller jusqu'à un zoom
numérique x 10 entre nous le zoom
numérique police il fait un petit peu
mal aux yeux
vous avez ensuite un ultra grand-angle 8
mégapixels avec un champ de vision de
118 degré qui ouvre à f 2.25 est en
dessous des 2 petite caméra de 2
mégapixels la première salle pour le
mode portrait pour les faits évoqués et
la deuxième pour de la macro jusqu'à 4
cm à l'avant vous avez une caméra de
saïfi qui est planqué ici 13 mégapixels
ouverture f 2.0 vous pouvez filmer à
l'arrière jusqu en 4k à 30 images par
seconde langue à capteur principal 12
mégapixels bon c'est pas officines en
extérieur il ya de la lumière c'est pas
dingue on n'est pas sur un smartphone
non plus complètement fou zoom x 2 ça
commence déjà un petit peu alice élan le
bois notamment au niveau du traitement
sur les feuilles x 2 x 5 x 5 salissent
beaucoup on récupère beaucoup de bruit
un qualité à l'épaule mais ça me paraît
pas complètement anormal ici on arrive
ensuite sur l' ultra grand-angle les
couleurs sont un peu moins belle c'est
pas terrible le boulot il n'est pas
extraordinaire là dessus
capteur principal x 2 x 510 ya du bruit
et luttera grand-angle ça permet de
faire des photos qui sont pas horrible
je dirais en conditions de bonne
luminosité mais c'est pas non plus là on
va avoir les meilleures photos et ça me
paraît normal une fois de plus 169 euros
caméra principale x 2 x 5 ultra
grand-angle on perd tout le détail on
perd toutes les couleurs c'est pas
terrible et on arrive sur le mode macro
l'an mode macro les sur une caméra 2
mégapixels récupère beaucoup de bruit on
a vraiment un lissage artificielle le
rendu pour moi là dessus il est pas du
tout qualitatif continue pareil bonne
macro j'essaye mode macro voyez c'est
très très lisse et c'est vraiment pas
très très très joli une fois de plus ce
mode macro caméra principale x 2 x 5
ultra grand temps que ce soir vous
n'avez pas ici de stabilisation optique
ni électronique dès que ça bouge ça
bouge c'est pas terrible et avec moi ça
ça ne pardonne pas caméra cette fille 13
mégapixels
bon ça fait le job assez correct c'est
pas dingue ça fait la ferme et une fois
de plus il ya pas de stades
l'électronique là dessus bon c'est pas
ouf on arrive ensuite sur le mode
portrait leurs notes rentrées
je trouve que il détour pas trop mal la
caméra on sort pas trop trop trop trop
trop trop mal
le job est fait il est là bon c'est pas
dingue mais ça marche on arrive ensuite
une fois de plus sur la jungle un petit
peu de marbre il fait un peu à l'aveuglé
le rendu est pas et pas d'un go ses
traits lissés au niveau des visages
néanmoins le détourage est correct moi
je trouve que regarder les yeux dans les
yeux le temps de tout bien calé c'est
bon vous bougez pas vous aider les
peuples a ajouté que par là moi ce
smartphone je trouve intéressant je
trouvais intéressant parce qu'il coûte
169 euros elle coûterait beaucoup plus
cher à bouddha c'est un peu moyen mais
169 euros vu ce que vous pouvez faire vu
les performances vu la grosse autonomie
que vous avez derrière si dans vos
usages vous avez un peu de jeu mais sans
vouloir à tout très extravagant si vous
voulez surtout un smartphone endurant
qui durant longtemps vous permet de
faire beaucoup de choses bien là vous
êtes vraiment satisfait après
effectivement falloir faire des
compromis au niveau notamment de la
qualité de l'écran on n'est pas sur une
superbe résolution on n'a pas d'écran
qui est complètement dingos donc si vous
voulez regarder vraiment beaucoup
contenus multimédias que voulait
vraiment le top de la qualité
vous l'avez pas l'expérience là dessus
elle est correcte elle est moyenne on
est sur un smartphone d'entrée de gamme
à 169 euros dont ça me dérange pas
vraiment à noter que vous n'avez pas de
smartphone qui est certifié résistants
étanche contre effectivement l'eau et la
poussière par contre il vit sur son site
nous annonce qu' il n'avait pas de
problème s'il rend compte de ça c'est
pas surprenant parce qu'il faut quand
même savoir qu'une certification il paye
ça coûte de l'argent je pense à peu près
vingt et quelques euros ou 20 et
quelques dollars par appareil donc ça ne
paraît pas déconnant qui ne l'est pas
fait ça pour tirer les cours vers le bas
ceci étant dit c'est un smartphone qui
me semble quand même plutôt bien
fabriqué plutôt résistants
je trouve qu'il est de bonne qualité
mais une fois de plus il s'adresse
vraiment à des personnes qui veulent pas
mettre beaucoup d'argent dans leurs
smartphones qui veulent acheter un
smartphone nu qui veulent pas un
smartphone avec abonnement 169 euros si
ça vous intéresse et bien je pense que
là dessus vous avez un très bon
smartphone et surtout un smartphone qui
se positionne face à d'autres
concurrents qui sont déjà bien
positionnés pour qu'il commence tout cas
être bien positionné et notamment chez
oblige pas comment vous trouvez vous
serez 2005
est-ce qu'il vous botte est ce qu'il
pourrait vous tentez de trouver ce petit
gène en arrière moi j'adore un scout et
holographique
alors on n'est pas sur un doux envers on
est sur le dos en plastique sauf qui est
quand même vachement bien son effet je
compte donc sur vous pour dire ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire et
sur ce je vous fais des gros bisous
donne rendez vous dès demain pour
continuer à parler de teck et puis tout
doucement se rapproche des fêtes de fin
d'année donc si vous êtes parti si vous
êtes en vacances je vous souhaite de
passer d'excellentes fêtes
et puis si vous travaillez bon courage
bonne fête à vous tous vous embrasse et
puis à demain ciao